それはまあちょこっと応用してみます
頭が硬い人間 物事は多数の側面を持っているんです
今日言いたいのはそれなんです
草の束が語ることでは
草の束が何を語ってますかね
草の束がおいしいですか？と尋ねると
普通の人は怒るんです
相手を笑う 質問した人を笑うんですね
まあこいつはおかしいんだと
相手がおかしいと思う
からかわれていると思う
あんた何様のつもりですかね？私にそんなこと聞くなとか
すごいそういう変な態度をとるんですよ
私は牛だと思ってるんですか？とかね
自分を侮辱されたとかね
からかわれたとかね あるいはこの人変やと相手をバカにしたりとか
それが普通の人のレスポンスも対応なんですよ
なんでそうなるんですかね
草の束もおいしいですから
これは真理の世界のことを聞いていますよ
一時的なことじゃなくて
絶対的な真理は何なのかと聞いてるんです
じゃなくて あんた人をバカにするんですか？と怒るんですよ
それは頭が硬いからなんです
それ その人に草はまずいに決まってるんです
怒った人はね あんた人をバカにするんですかと反論したら
イエスノーという人よりももっとバカなんです
イエスノーという人はただ恥かげられるだけで
あんた草食べてるでしょうと
それで冗談で笑って話は終わりますけど
負けたと怒った人がもっと無知なんです
イエスもノーも言わないで
なぜならば この人にとっては草はまずいと決まってるんです
草に 1側面しかないという偏見に陥っているんです
草と見たら自分だけの偏見
これしかないんだよと
牛にどう見えるか ヤギにどう見えるか
ヒツジにどう見えるか
鳥にどう見えるかとかね
それはどうでもいいんです
鳥たちが草を取って巣を作ったりもしますしね
それはどうでもいい 草はもう 1側面しか持ってないという
すごい偏見なんですね
これは しかし 汝には私を語れませんと草が言ってるんです
草は何？あんた方にはね
私を語れませんということを言ってるんです
だから怒ったり いろいろ興奮したりする人はもうより無知なんです
答えとしてハメられる人は
その時点でまあ可愛いんですけど
それでもなく何言うんでしょうかというと
もうまずいに決まってるっていう答えでしょうに
結局は 草の束が我々は無知であることを証言するんです
だから草の束はおいしいですかということ
草の束というセクションが
人間は本来無知であるということなんです
そこまで読めますかね
その問答で 草の束って言えば
これは生命は無知であるということなんです
だから結構立派ですよ
草の束でしたってもね
それさえも語れないんだから
我々人間には 無知な人にすべては決まっているんです
じゃあ 決まっている世界に行ってみましょう
靴は足に履くもので 野良犬を追い出すために投げる道具ではありませんね
決まってるでしょ 野良犬が来ると自分の靴を脱いで
それは何やってるのかと
それは足に履くものに決まってるんだよと
カミソリは紙なのに髭を剃るために決まっている
髪を切るために別な道具があるんだよと
カミソリで髪切ろうと思っちゃうと
いや それは髭を剃ったらカミソリという必要もないんですけど
それはダメですよと 別にカッターとかなんとか使ってくださいと
それでカッターも一応何にも使ってない場合
結構切れますからね それでちょっと髭でも剃ってみようかなと思っちゃうと
またバラバラじゃうんですね
何々に決まっているという考えで
我々はよく落ち着くんですね
物知りになって気分がいいんです
カッターは髪を切ったり
色のそれに決まってあって
髪それはひげをするために決まってあって
靴は足に履くことに決まってあってとかね
このカバンは女性が使うカバンにあるカバンであることを決まってあるとかね
これは男性用のカバンであるとかね
全部決まってるんです
そう知っていると結構物知りですよ
あまり女性男性差別ない
カバン買う時って やっぱりこの色は女性向きだから
これはやめやめてくださいとかね
えらい物知りでしょう
誰が決まったんですかね
そんなことは だから物は決まっているという人は
本当に極限に無知なんですよ
その上落ち着くんですね
もう決まってるんだから困ることはないでしょう
それを上 私は何でも知ってるんだぞというその気分
何も考えて困る必要ないんです
そういう人々には ですから
我々に世の中で無数の道具があるんですよ
何々に決まってるから
道具はいくら開発してもまだ足りません
またまた何か作るんです
道具に抑えられて こういう漢字がもうちょっとおかしいね
でもそれでもいい そうですか
抑えられて自由が失っているんです
我々は自分で作った道具なんですが
道具たちが我々をぎゅっと抑えられているんです
自由がないんです 道具が
道具はあるが 何に使うべきかもわからないこともあるんです
まあ時々道具 時とか電子レンジとかね
あれいっぱいいろんなプログラム
あれ 何に使いますかね
さっぱりわかりません
私にも 1つありますけど
ただ 2分に合わせてレンジでボタンを押すしか一回も他使ったことはないんです
だから道具はあるんだけど
何に使うかってことさえもわからない世界に生きているんです
道具とは 物が持っている多面性を極力少なくして
できれば 1側面にすることです
それで今日の講演 テーマ
講演のテーマは 物事はこれはこれである
これは決まっているということは不可能です
どんなものも多面的多面性を持っています
だから草の束を持ってきたんですよ
これは調べてみるととんでもない真理を語っているんです
悟りの境地を表現しているんです
そこまであります 側面が
しかし 無知な人はこれで困りますね
1側面にしようとするんですよ
これ どれほどひどいかというと
複数の側面を持っているものを 1側面にしようとする
例えば刃物 切るものあるでしょうね
どれぐらい種類あるか知ってます？物を切るものは
私も知りません 無数にありますよ
まあ西洋的な台所だったら
もう包丁も 40種類ぐらいありますからね
ピーラーにしたってもね
いろんな種類のピーラーがあるんですよ
中国人だけですね 包丁一つ
あれで無数の料理作るんですよ
もう包丁 40つぐらい使ってる西洋人にはできる料理は本当にレパートリーが少ないんですね
それで包丁一つしか使わない中国人に聞いてみると
作る料理の数々はもうあまりにも知らない
中国人さえも だから このただ刃物にしてみたっても
あまりにもたくさんありますよ
私は思い出したのは 例えばこのお医者さんのね
外科のところに行ってみると
人の体切る道具もどれぐらいあると思いますかね
ものすごいたくさんありますよ
一つだけ持って全部手術終了するということはないんです
レーザーで切る機械もあるし
いろんなありますよ だからそれであの
例えばレーザーもものすごいたくさんありますよ
それにそのそのレーザー線に一つの仕事しかできないんです
例えば体のもう中を切る場合もね
あまりあのもう血が出て困りますからね
レーザーでしっと切る場合もあるし
体の中内臓を切るためにあるレーザーで外は切れません
外を切るために使うレーザーあれだったら
それで内臓を切るためには使えません
使えないんです そういうふうに
この道具っていうのは
この多側面を全部捨てちゃって一側面にするという
恐ろしい残酷なことなんです
それは無理 無理と思いますけどね
そんなことやったってもね
だって台所の包丁で人を殺してるでしょうに
普通の何かいろんな大事なことに使うために作って
ロープでみんな自殺してるでしょうに
だから一側面にすることはできないんですよ
例えばビニールのロープとかあるでしょ？あの黄色いと黒い色で巻いてきれいな格好いいものとかね
これはまあ こういうこういうものに使うものであると
他のものには使えないんだそうと言えますかね
使えますよ 包丁は魚と魚の肉と野菜を切るためにあるんだと
他のものは切れませんよと
これは無理です だからみんな頑張ってるんですよ
この 1側面にしようと
しかし ものは多素多側面持ってますからね
だからマッチはね あのタバコを吸うためとかね
ロウソクに火をつけるためにあると決まってるんですけどね
それで あの 何といいますか
あの 放火もするんですよ
建物とか丸ごとにもう放火して燃やしたりもします
だから  で決まってるのは悪用で
ものだけ決まって まあちょっと犬が落ちてますけど
としても決まってるとしても構わないが
他人のこと 自分のことまで決まってるという枠にはめておくんです
私が言いたいのは 包丁の使い方決まってるんだ
調理の使い方決まってる
まあまあいいや もうめんどくさいんだからと無視することできますよ
ものだからね しかし 我々はそれを悪用しているので
決まってる法則を 人間のことも決まっていると
自分のことも決まっていると
だからちょっと考えてほしい
ものに決まってるっていうことも
ものすごい無知で乱暴で
あまりにも大胆な もう過激的というか
もうもうテロリスト行為なんです
それ人生命に当てはめると
もう話にならないんです
人間関係が それ何でしたっけ
で まあとにかくなんか分からないんですけど
知らない感じが入っちゃって
まあ崩れててもいいし
で あの苦労することになるんですね
なんで我々は人間関係で苦労してますかね？これ決まってる法則ですよ
それさえなければ別に問題ないんです
相手が私のことを批判するに決まってると思えば
その人と仲良く会話をすることができないでしょ
だから我々は日常生活の中でいつでも
あの人はこれこれこれこれで決まっている
この人はこの子の性格で決まっていると頭ごなしに思っているんだから
その人と喋るたびに その何て言いますか
その色眼鏡で見て喋ってるんです
だから決して良い人間関係というのは全くも成り立ちません
これすごい恐ろしいことなんですよ
だから物に 草の束を馬鹿にしちゃうと
これとんでもない失礼でしょうに
これ真理語ってるのに
智慧のある人に これもっと人間関係に持ってくると
テロリストよりも残酷ひどいことをやっていることになるんです
これは冗談の例で まあ一応良いことですけど
私はモテないに決まっていると思ったらね
ならば好意を持つ人がいてもダメになるんですよ
あること私はモテないと決まっている
どこ行ってもモテないんだと思ったとしても
誰かの人がやっぱりその人に好意を持つ可能性はあるでしょうに
好意を持ったって この人はちょっと怪しいと
あっち行きなさいよとなんとか失礼なことを言って
それさえも壊れてしまいますよ
まあ一応モテない方が一番安全で便利なんですけど
あの 一応まあそうやって自分に対しても何か決まっておけば
物事はうまくいかないんです
宗教では 宗教になってくると
他宗教の人々は地獄に落ちることに決まっていると説くんです
これ面白いんですよ で
日蓮宗教の人の話を見ると
みんな他の人はもう地獄もかい
全天馬とかなんとか言ってますからね
よく言うこと 頭賢いと思ってるんですかね
イスラム教はイスラム
アッラー信仰しない連中はみんな地獄に落ちるんだと
キリスト教は宗派がたくさんありますから
それぞれのパターンで信仰しないと
もう地獄やと直行で 例えばカトリック教とプロテスタントってすごい教えが違いますからね
プロテスタントの人から見れば
ローマを信仰したら もうそれはダメですよってことを言うでしょう
死んだらどうなるのかって
やっぱりわからないんですね
死んだらやっぱりカトリック教の人でも
まあキリスト教だから天国行くんだったら
あんたの宗教別にいらんでしょうと
ということになるんです
宗教家でありながら激しい人間差別ですよ
思考に決まっているというウイルスが入ると
仏教は邪見だと注意するんです
この決まってるっていうことは何とかしなさいよと
これが邪見であると お釈迦様が邪見者が地獄に落ちるんだよという
ということで みんなダメですね
どうしようもないです
東教であろうとも 仏教であろうとも
決まってるということで来てるならば
もう邪見なんです だからそこは論理的に地獄に落ちるんだと言うでしょう
だから残酷なことだからね
決まってると思うことで
物事に対してすごい残酷な態度を取ってますよ
で 魂があるに決まってる
死後往生するように決まってる
いろいろ宗教でね 決まってることいっぱいあるんです
そういうのは全部邪見です
それからそれでこの人間の頭が硬いというテーマでしたからね
決まってるっていうことは
頭がいいじゃなくて ものすごい硬い
柔軟性がない 心理に開放していないんです
で それと怠けというものをつなげてきます
物事は決まっていると定めてしまって落ち着いたと思うことは怠けなんです
肉体怠けというよりも
これ知恵 知恵の怠け 心の怠けなんですね
世界に見られる開発は怠けから現れるのです
また 物質世界に戻りますけど
世界でいろんな開発がありますね
あれは全部怠けるためにやっているんです
怠けたいんです だから何か開発するんです
便利という考えで開発することは理性的ですが
結局はそれも怠けを応援することになるんです
例えば これは便利やと思って何か道具を開発する
それは構いませんよ わざと不便な生活をする必要ないんだから
しかし そういう理性があっても
結局は怠けっていうことは応援しちゃうんです
思考の怠けは邪見を起こすんです
だから肉体的怠けじゃなくて
邪見っていうのはこの思考の怠けなんです
思考の怠けが妄想ばかりを起こして人を不幸にするんです
だから 思考しない人はものすごい勢いで妄想するんです
思考すると 思考はすごくデータに則って管理しなくちゃいけないんだからね
例えば草の束の問題でも
ただ当てもなく考えちゃうと
これ何年考えるんですかね
私はその問題を作った時点で分析して終わったと
話が終わりました これも冗談で
どこかから来たあるお坊さんがいて
あなたは日本の宗教に対してどう思いますか？なんとかと言って聞かれた時は
ただ冗談でからかってやろうかなと言ってね
で これに答えるんでしょうか
その瞬間に考えて出した答えが質問なんです
それで講演に使おうかなと
もうネタがあまりないんだからね
あれ使おうかなと まあ使っただけで
それで分析して終わったらそれで話終わりですよ
私の分析以外 誰にも語るところはないと思いますよ
決まってるんではなくて
まあ一応全部 そういうことで
思考ない人が妄想して妄想して
それすごい恐ろしいエネルギーで妄想するんです
それで邪見でしょうし
だからもうものすごいひどく不幸な
不幸から不幸へ 不幸から不幸へ行く道を選ぶんですね
怠けと創造力の対立 まあ子供たちには
なんか変ですね 家にあるペットボトルなどを使っていろいろなものを作ることを教えるんですね
小学生とか幼稚園とかね
いろんなもうペットボトルを持っていて
段ボール箱を持っていて
まあいろんなものを作ったんです
作るでしょ？工作とかなんとか言って
それで子供たちは決まってるっていうことじゃなくて
例えば私から見たんだけど
ペットボトル半分切って
これで鉛筆筆入れを作ったりとかね
それでまたいろいろ模様を描いたり
ちょっとかっこよく作ったりとかね
であるんだから ペットボトルはそれに決まってるわけじゃないんです
いろんなものに使える
だから一側面ではないんです
ペットボトルで あの 何て言いますか
あの 風が吹くと回るやつはなんて言いますか
風車 きれいな風車を作ったりもするでしょうね
あっち向こうに立てたりして
それで風が吹くと ずっとぐるぐるぐるぐる回ったりして
時々それは畑で鳥を追い出すためにも使っているでしょうに
もし頭硬くて決まってるんだったら
そのアイデアが浮かばないでしょうに
だからもう自分の畑に鳥が来るわ
面倒くさいわ まあペットボトルで風車作って
そしてはそこはあんまり派手に回すんだから
鳥たちが怯えて来ないというね
ということで この物にこの性質決まっていると思うことは良くないし
まあ何にも使えるぞということは一番いいんですよ
だからそれは子供たちには偉そうに教えますけど
創造力を刺激しようと努力もしますよ
子供たちの場合は同時に徹底的に道具に慣らさせるんですね
それ教えながら 子供たちはまたこの決まってる道具使ってくださいって
これはこれに決まってる
これはこれに決まってるとかね
例えば子供がはさみで何かドーンとさせて
ダメダメだよと ハサミはそれに使いませんよ
そこでもう矛盾です 決まってるパターンで生きることが教育だとするんです
本当は教育っていうのは
人間をあるパターン 決まってるパターンで生かせることなんです
だから恐ろしいんです
人に本来あるべきインスピレーションやら創造力が大人になると極限に減るでしょ
どんどん我々はすごい自由自在に生まれたのに
それはいかに小さくするのかということを大人になる過程なんです
だから死ぬ時 みんな惨めなんです
すっごい明るくて 私はもう偉い
そうと偉いんだぞと生きてるのはちっちゃな子供たちだけなんです
成功者の頭は柔軟 それ反対のこと
だから世の中で成功するということは
柔軟な頭を持っているということなんです
このたられば思考は敗北の宣言なんです
もうはっきりできないと言ってるんだからね
私の頭が硬いと これはもう大きくはなりませんよと
曲がりませんよと だからたられば思考になってくると
美味しいんではないんですけど
一応敗北 宣言にはなります
柔軟な人はあるものでなんとかして問題を解決する
乗り越える だから問題っていうのは今起きる
だったら今解決しなくちゃいけない
そうすると 今あるもので解決しなくちゃいけないんです
それが成功者なんです
こう たらればを持ってくると
もう問題は解決しないんですね
それで負けちゃうでしょう
ものは多側面だと知っている人は
手に入る は何に使えるかと考えるんです
例えば柔軟性ある人で
まあこれはもうはっきり決まってる道具ですね
あのポインターとしてもこうやって使えるんですけど
コンピューターのもういく分の管理はできます
これで それに決まってますかね
これは 別なことはできるはずなんですけど
だから頭が柔軟性だったら
まあそういう仕事もできますけど
また別な仕事もできますよと
例えば私の場合 ちょっと線でも引くことになったならば
何のことなくこれを使いますよ
ちょっとあ 真っ直ぐだ
じゃあこれ使おうと 定規がないんでしょうか
なんとかとか それはないんです
これで十分です 新しい使用方法
アイデアが現れるんですよ
だからまあどんなものでもね
見たら別なアイデアもいくらでもアイデアマンでいろんなアイデアが出てくるもんです
ではこうしましょうとひらめく人は成功者ですよ
何か見たら あ これだったらこうしましょうよと思うならば
それはもう成功者ですよ
ああ どうしようではないんです
どうしようたらればと悩むのは無知
怠け 頑固の敗北者です
どうしようと言っちゃうとアウトですね
え？